towering over the city the Soviet
Embassy in Havana was opened in the
1980s the high point of Cuban Soviet
relations after the USSR disintegrated
Cuban Russian relations hit rock bottom
before slowly Reviving over the last two
decades
but as this former Cuban Diplomat points
out recently the relationship has become
much stronger if you take the speeches
and the
political pronunciations of 10 years ago
I think Raul Castro himself said we have
three strategic allies
China Venezuela and Vietnam he didn't
mention Russia
yet if you say that today
who are these Cuba's strategic allies
Russia will come in the first place
the Catalyst the war in Ukraine Russia
is not only a native allies but hemmed
in by Western sanctions it needs trading
partners and places to invest
both Nations Russia and Cuba have unjust
sanctions imposed on them that originate
from the same enemy the Yankee Empire
Havana's position on the war in Ukraine
has shifted over time at first it said
that NATO expansion formed the backdrop
to the conflict but it opposed the use
of force a reference to Russia's
Invasion Vengeance at the UN Cuba has
consistently abstained from condemning
The Invasion
while the U.S and its NATO allies have
rallied around Ukraine as the war has
progressed Cuba has thrown its lot in
with Russia Cuban president Miguel
descanel this may even offer his
country's unconditional support to
Russia's clash with the West
meanwhile Russia is providing Cuba with
unprecedented economic support
trade between the two countries tripled
last year and is up again this year
mostly Russian oil deliveries which are
helping to keep the lights on
amid a flurry of trips by senior
officials this year Cuba has given
Russian companies long-term land
concessions and tax breaks
nothing and no one can stop the economic
commercial financial and Cooperative
relationship between the governments of
Russia and Cuba
Russia has announced investments in
Cuban hotels liquor and the dilapidating
sugar industry
after reneging on normalization
successive U.S administrations have
lashed the island with sanctions over
the last six years with its economy and
shreds Cuba is looking for help wherever
it can find it
a Russian warship Doctrine Havana last
week Grist to the mill for the U.S
political right that's trying to present
Cuba as a national security threat
this ever closer relationship forged by
world events makes any reproachment with
the US even trickier Ed Augustine Al
Jazeera Havana